one of the things that we don't talk
about culturally is that a lot of women
do not know how to be with or receive or
see a man's vulnerabilities for a lot of
women it's very frightening it's foreign
imagine being a woman who grew up around
a grandfather and a father who never
cried who never opened up who never
talked about their feelings and then all
of a sudden here's your husband or
here's your boyfriend opening up
spilling his guts out emotionally crying
in front of you and you're just like
what do I do with this you know and so
I've heard pretty bad stories where men
have opened up to their girlfriends and
all of a sudden 2 months later their
relationship's over or the sexual
attraction's gone or the conversations
suddenly get stilted